clothes you know in five four three two
one
what's up everybody welcome to a very
special quarantine episode of the genius
brain podcast before you bitch-ass
[ __ ] say anything yeah Joe
Rogan has been having guests on and so
what we found out in LA County that
podcasts and news stations are actually
comes deemed essential businesses so we
can still run I didn't know that so
yesterday yeah so if you look it up on
that LA website we're all we're all
still good to go all of us here have a
nozzle in contact with anybody else
yep I've been going to the grocery store
with Mike a n95 mask i sanitized that
[ __ ] with hydrogen peroxide as per
recommended Oh got the gloves on and
also you other [ __ ] you should
be sharing your K n95 mask well guess
what [ __ ] if you have your can 95
mess and you try to donate it to the
hospital without the box
they don't accept it no so it's not like
that like if you have two or three they
won't even take it like that so shut the
[ __ ] up and stay safe people god bless
you and I hope we're out Podcast great
the fact that you have to like do a
disclaimer before you ever well that's
what it is made so I was at the the
supermarket the other day and it was so
funny because this lady I didn't have my
K in 95 I had that I have my my fiance's
mask with a cute little bear the front
[ __ ] you everybody I got one with
monkeys all over it yeah and then he was
lady gave this other lady [ __ ] because
she had a KN 95 mess right and the first
thing she says to her in the in the
supermarket line or the grocery line at
the checkout line that's what it's
called check she was in the vegetable
she was epiha and then she goes uh you
should probably donate your K and 95
mass due to uh to medical workers yeah
let me just take it right off my face
and give it to them exactly right and so
the lady had to do this whole diatribe
and she had to go into this whole
explanation she goes uh no I only have
to and even if I try to donate it I
can't because it has to be stored into a
box and it's none of your [ __ ]
business exact why does she have to say
that [ __ ] yeah what kind of nerve does
somebody have to say that to a complete
stranger everybody know that everything
dudes like I wear the
n95 because I have a client well we
talked to bond on the other podcasts yes
like super prone to getting sick if
something were to get him sick he gets
really sick so I only wear my n95 mask
to him yeah like I'm not gonna donate
them because I need them because when
I'm around him I'm trying to be as safe
as I can because I don't want to bring
anything into him yeah I don't say
there's a certain business IVM for
details there's like certain I'm selling
a KN 95 nothing illegal but people do
people are so nosy and if people want to
walk around without a mask and they want
to like gather in big groups
let them do to give the [ __ ] yeah but
they can't even out here without a mask
on you can't I just went to Target today
because I had to pick up some stuff and
they have a sign that says if you don't
have a mass they won't even let you in
again some markets without a mask on
I'll tell you this though right now I'm
that snitch David so in public and he's
taking a picture of you it's because
you're violating and unemployment was
taking a big minute I was like I'm about
to me start they'd be you know what's
[ __ ] funny every time I scratch my
face I've been doing that to do it even
like in Shane's amount I have hand
sanitizer bottle in my car I have one in
my bathroom in my little cabinet that I
have in my bathroom I have one in my
room I have hand sanitizer everywhere
and then I have some in my fanny pack
yes sweep I mean that is glitter this
does nothing but I like the smell of it
and it's 68 percent alcohol don't you
need like 70 percent no I think it's
ester that's the right amount so if you
if you go too much I don't know the size
behind it because I read it loosely but
if you have too high of an alcohol
content something about water bonding
molecules or some [ __ ] doesn't allow I
think it was like see I think I read
that to like 60 70 percent those little
blue beads in here is what saves you
from kovat that's what's that's the most
when they help but you would have the
fruitiest one ever dude I ran out of my
other ones alright what if gave me okay
this cute one do you think you're better
than me because you have a more manly a
low-key I never liked the sprays I feel
like it's not enough I'm the person that
like needs to do the whole I'll see
that's the exponential part this is just
water dude FDA approved you know that
sour spray it's only 62% so I'm not even
lying right Madurai just open this up
and it just smells like soju I was like
rubbing alcohol
these [ __ ] Korean [ __ ]
playing with me right now he said what's
so job you do you don't know what's owed
you is that's Korean alcohol bro well
you don't really drink though you know
oh you don't drink why not
I just never like to taste I got the
back so back in Arizona I live him stay
rubbing that this was straight up in his
cornea
you know what it is I don't know what it
is I'll go back to that story for a
second but I've been playing video games
like a [ __ ] no not on the
quarantine and I think like it was funny
I was playing so late some nights like
until 1:30 2:00 a.m. and I told myself
I'm like man I'm gonna get like a sty on
my eye you know how like it like swells
up so is that how you get stars I don't
know I don't think so but in my head on
my own playing these games so much I'm
about to get a sty am I in like two days
later do my [ __ ] was so fat and swollen
right on the inside I was like it's like
a pimple in your eyes almost yeah and I
was like damn like and I called that
[ __ ] like it for real god I think it's
maybe just from not having enough sleep
and just keeping your eyes open so now
you don't know sighs I need I need one
of those Jamie's from like Joe Rogan
podcast I know can we say stupid [ __ ]
somebody could just help us say honestly
people will let us know in the YouTube
comments though before but I remember
the first time I might have died just
look like a pimple look like a pimple in
my head and that [ __ ] [ __ ] hurt dude
I woke up in the morning and I just went
just I closed my eyes really hard and it
hurt and I was supposed to put like a
warm towel on it or something
yeah poison I don't know what the warm
towel does was supposed to do nothing
all right so watch I'm gonna tell you to
start right on like alcohol right so
back when I lived in Arizona we lived
right right next to ASU campus right so
my friends had an apartment and I just
started giving them like two
your bucks and I was sleeping on the
couch right so can you homey [ __ ]
charge you just to sleep on the couch a
dog well so here's the thing right
hey that dowel Wow my guy has so many
different lives
I'll get my dick sucked my raccoon they
lived on ASU campus like right outside I
think if people from Arizona listen to
this it was like kind of by Lemon Street
or some [ __ ] food in the lake hella fast
- no there's always on rapping [ __ ] they
look like it nummies people when on my
19th birthday so I never I drank every
once in a while like I used to drink a
lot of Old English and like the thing
that we used to do is like drink a
little bit maybe like this much and then
pour some tampico and have your hand st.
Pico that's a big so you drink a little
bit poor I think it's good gas monkey
your monkeys were make you were mixing
Old English with a Tempe Co yeah why
Tampico yikes
I used to be able to drink it like I
would do those 40 ounces man you drink
halfway and you're already like tossed
right so it was I think was my 19th
birthday and uh what's it called my
friends had Captain Morgan yeah look at
mo okay so that was the first time I
ever had it I do
I think there's video of the day that
we're drinking it right I think yeah I
think there's video there so I had seven
shots right and they just [ __ ] me up
so I woke up the next morning right and
I guess throughout that time my roommate
Andre at the time told me he's like yo
like you literally woke up in the middle
of the night and ate like half a loaf of
bread I'm sorry hold on bro that is the
truth that that's who you are
that is our driest thing you could have
ever had so I thought [ __ ] did you eat
half a loaf abridgement soak up the
alcohol no no no
no this was me blacked out drunk I
didn't know I did it so the next morning
I woke up right and like I was hella
sick so I go to go throw up and I'm
literally having to force like oh
squeeze and it's just slow like bread
just slowly coming bro and I came out I
got you ever use a juicer before and
then the Pope come on dude that [ __ ] was
so thick and I was just yeast literally
[ __ ] had a force it out like and I
went out and I was telling my home and
he's like yeah bro you look woke up in
the middle of the night in ain't half of
the [ __ ] bread you weren't hungover
though huh I was dog that [ __ ] so I was
sick for like a couple days and ever
since then just like any liquor or
alcohol or liquor in general like
straight-up liquor I can't even drink
dude it makes me a movie liquor blame it
on you eating half a loaf of bread like
a Russian prisoner dude they never say
any white bread yeah wonder no but yes
so like any liquor it's just I you know
you don't wanna get sick off of
something like food or something you
take a bike I'm just like yeah it's the
same thing with liquor and then beer I
just I don't understand how that [ __ ]
tastes good people hey see I used to be
like that too when I first started
YouTube but I had a video that
lightweight went kind of viral it was me
talking [ __ ] about people who drink
alcohol right because I hated that [ __ ]
I hated the way that it tastes and it
was more of a social thing right yeah so
when your boys would ask you to drink
you would drink the first [ __ ] alcohol
I have ever had I think I was like in
seventh grade or some eighth grade uh
how old that was but it was Remy Martin
and I had this you had Remy Martin in
eighth grade yeah I didn't know what the
[ __ ] why did you do this so I had the
egg
I saw Remy Martin it was me and my
cousin and he got some from I don't know
how the [ __ ] he got I think got it from
his dad and then he poured it into like
this the Crystal Geyser water bottle and
we were just drinking it out of that and
then I remember my cousin um is a yo you
could drink a lot I don't even know what
the [ __ ] that means I'm just drinking
this nasty-ass liquid but we got smashed
and mind you like I pretty sure I
mentally [ __ ] me up yeah you shouldn't
be drinking that much alcohol but I
found out that I could pretty much hold
my liquor pretty well from that point on
but I drank starting like yeah when I
was like 13 ish around there and I just
kept doing it only because
as people knew that I could drink a lot
and it was just one of those things that
everybody will start drinking together I
was I would still be the one standing
and everybody'd be [ __ ] passed out I
feel like a lot of Korean dudes or
people that I know all could drink like
real a lot I can't really drink much
anymore though I have like maybe four or
five drinks and I'm I'm about four or
five that's a lot did I drink one like
and I'm like yo I feel buzzed though my
buddy Paul Kim this [ __ ] is
dangerous without Tim - Tim can trigger
[ __ ] he drew keep drinking I'll put a
clip in this video later on this is
video of me I don't remember doing this
[ __ ] but this was at cent Foods right so
we were at this we were at Pittsburgh
and we got this festival called pickles
bird they have been known for a pickled
beer which is really good by the way you
probably won't like it you don't like
beer hey like though you like pickles
here yeah hey pickles like slap it
depends I don't understand you know when
you go to the gas station they're
selling pickles I'm like that's that
[ __ ] though like I remember I'll just
grab a ice-cold pickle I speak much sir
yummy dude yeah I never like wake up or
out the day it's like ha my fault I
wanna pick you ever get a pickle at
Disneyland
no I don't know three times let's go
it's actually a lot compared to most
people did they say someone broken into
yeah just like couple days ago what for
what no you can for what
hey Mickey yeah but we were at we are
[ __ ] Pittsburgh and then for some
reason that day we were drinking a lot
and this is where I found out how much
Tim can drink so we had I had a pickle
beer which is already a can like yeah
this is the co-host yeah yeah mmm and
then we had like three glasses of wine
and then we had like two mixed drinks
like a shot of something else and
another beer and this is all within a
span of like of like 20 or 30 minutes
but we were having such a good time yeah
I wasn't you know just like whatever
we're a lot of you too so when you eat a
lot of food and you're drinking it kind
of gets delayed because of all the food
in your stomach before so I still absorb
into your your bloodstream or whatever
yeah low and behold I haven't drank like
that in a long time I don't remember
this [ __ ] but Tim has a video of me
trying to roundhouse kick a water bottle
off of a pole a [ __ ] like a video
tutorial I don't remember this [ __ ] at
all but he said it to me I'm just red as
[ __ ] am i hang
that one okay from him with thank you
that happens to me too when I drink
beers and Shai get red as [ __ ] oh I was
[ __ ] and then apparently I went to the
hotel I do slightly remember this is
because there was this big sandwich that
they had out in Pittsburgh that written
a note for the sandwich spot
apparently the sandwich from what I
remember it fell on the floor and I was
so drunk I just want to eat something I
just ate top floor back in bed you're
like best sandwich ever it was yeah at
it I was like straightedge which to like
16 17 which I can lose you know like
reality I don't think you can beat
straightest you didn't even like legally
able to drink or smoke anyway so it's
like they're not even supposed to be
doing it you know I'm saying but anyways
it we used to rep straightedge so like I
just remember I said again just a rep
straightedge yeah these would tell
people like oh no I'm straight I
straight up so I used to have like
straightedge shirts that have like the
big X on that forw used to do that what
the [ __ ] is storage straightedge means
you don't drink you don't smoke and
don't do drugs and then sometimes people
like you don't have sex I'm like what's
it called yeah so we used to rep
straight as I've ever had these little
bike because I used to be in a deathcore
band right so we were like in the
hardcore style scene and [ __ ] I also
that you explain me what the [ __ ] death
chorus is dude don't you ever [ __ ] do
that again on this so yeah just
screaming explain to me what the [ __ ]
you just did right now you know hey this
will be cool for a listen I'm gonna show
you guys how to scream you guys ready no
that's coming in ready alright so
basically what it is this is how I
learned back in the day right took a lot
of practice so the breathing technique
is like if you're fogging up a window so
you're going so you use a lot of your
like diaphragm right ok so then next is
like you know matching you're taking a
[ __ ] and you know when you get that you
know you get that fatter that fat little
dingle you're trying to push it out and
you go like that noise mmm hoist okay
you [ __ ] like that huh you [ __ ] like
that
absolutely I'm trying to imagine
now I move this side you know when you
[ __ ] and you go no bro nobody shoots
like that anybody's ears right so then
so then you kind of just put that
together so the breathing technique is
and then you put the together you put
that together oh and it just depends on
like how you do your mouth so I can go
really low and then you can go you can
do it like real high sorry
people like listen like listen to the
[ __ ] I do one time I went in his car and
he started playing music it was this
[ __ ] knows I hate walk it's cool it was
in the middle of the freeway what you
know about this stop right now say I we
used to be in that and that was like the
thing like straightedge shredders kind
of like a gang out there sort of [ __ ]
annoying I know that's popular right
like it was like you had the people like
now I can go to sleep but that was it
was huge in that scene was straight I've
never heard of a deathcore before so
it's like a mixture of death metal I
might begin this wrong this is just my
what I thought what I think it's like a
make sure a death metal which is like a
lot of fast like yeah melodic and like
you know fast like [ __ ] tremolo well
that's what's a band that you would say
is death metal death metal yeah uh
[ __ ] lighter that names horns with a
K I guess kind of corn like old style I
would know when dubstep sort of I feel
like what would you categorize those
guys like corn corn like metal just
metal death metal is more of like I'd
say like a Slayer they're kind of like a
Thrasher
style metal but Slayer or like a black
dahlia murderer is a really good like
dark black death metal stuff like that
so you take your mixture of like The
Tremeloes and blastbeats and like the
cool guitar riffs and then you have
hardcore music which is a lot of like
slam in two steps and [ __ ] and you put
it together so it's like super heavy we
used to play what my brother was the
guitarist and we had this other
guitarist we play with 7-string guitars
so we had like an extra like deep chord
so it'd be really heavy and [ __ ] this is
that Satan music basic that's what
everybody calls yeah the devil music and
the coal was it was funny you have like
a cool little intro have like a good to
step to go into that [ __ ] that [ __ ] led
into a fat ass breakdown that's when
everybody starts doing that swingin [ __ ]
the hardcore dance in imagine this
[ __ ] in a mosh pit
bro your boy I liked in beginning and
then the whole thing with that music
scene and kind of we got turned off on
it because it turned to like I know it's
huge and people still like a people
liking this [ __ ] I don't understand it's
like yeah someone's knocking yeah I'll
have a question one second so dig it's
talking to a guy that works here and he
was before
yeah the way he was knocking I was
scared I thought he was like pissed at
us or something
no I dunno I was I was kind of hyped
because I thought it was probably about
to be the cops and we like we essential
[ __ ] get out of here oh it's so crazy
how sometimes a knock on the door can
seem so aggressive and I see this man
and he has such a nice demeanor I was
like here because the headphones are
yeah in that I thought you were knocking
or something I thought you were making
my magic or wow you're making a beat
like under the table like boom I was
saying by a death metal that's sick my
favorite bands were like Oceano the
Acacia Strain ii mirror those bands if
you if you're trying to look for
business person I've ever met it yeah
like I've never met anyone that loves
death metal and used to play death metal
but also loves hip-hop and hey so I know
you do I know it's this funny story
about that right so how I got involved
or Salvadori
and ie mangle with the ski I like how it
started was we know my dad used to like
Slayer and [ __ ] right and Iron Maiden
you guys know Iron Maiden news no so no
that's our teacher have another song
that talked about it okay so yeah like
we were used to play Tony Hawk pro
skater 3 you guys remember that game
yeah so there was a cool game called
cool song called the number of the beast
by Iron Maiden so me and my brothers
just the [ __ ] wait well this is cool so
I remember we gonna when I asked my dad
like a do you know this song he's like
why y'all like hmm well I guess all
right bet hold up and then like start
satellite Isaac yeah he said I guess
respect what makes you like that type of
music because I mean is it there's I
don't hear the Mel I don't hear any yeah
it's your weird scream like think about
it I don't know I really don't know
is it like because you had a lot of like
sexual angst or some [ __ ] as like a team
now cuz that song straight up about like
the devil and [ __ ] oh really get the
[ __ ] I don't remember the lyrics fully
it's weird I don't know I guess I was
really drawn into like the instruments
in I really like when choruses get like
upbeat and I like when music can make
you feel like a certain way right so
like if a love song like before I let
you go you know I'm saying my xbox last
night and then he was like streaming
live and he started singing that song
other people rely yo that's not slaps
who is that oh no
but yeah so whatever long story short so
I used to like that [ __ ] right we were
into it but I was always into rap so
like eazy-e was my favorite rapper I
used to wear like a eazy-e shirt all the
time NWA dr. Dre all that type of stuff
so I used to write raps like that was
the music I liked a lot was raps I
remember but the first rap I ever wrote
was about sonic 2 sonic restaurant right
and I remember I went and read it to my
dad [ __ ] fat [ __ ] about Sonic the
burger joint you remember how it goes I
don't remember that one no you need to
recite the lyrics right now you got to
find the right now they need you to fire
original beat and lyrics they wrote -
well now ok done for man live go tell
you this was a lot when I was like in
third grade for me
happy hour and then so like I did like
music and then when I got into 6th grade
is when like I really started writing
more rap music and when we performed at
a talent show for like our pod and we
won right I wrote a song called black
shoes and we performed in front of
everybody and it was cool what was black
shoes about black shoes I put my black
shoes on with the null white shirt oh
look at me like I look like dirt
forget them fools I ain't no fool huh I
ride on 20 photos on my way to school no
I ain't black but I ain't white ass know
I get a lot of stuff like I lost the toe
I got a lot of friends a lot of me and a
lot of money
I don't like sugar but I like honey
honey I'm being six favorite kind of
food is a cherry pop tart for eight I'm
not that tall so in the bathroom I pee
in the stuff I know how to sing the ABCs
black just and tell her so I don't eat
cheese I'm about to go right about now
bad don't want to answer any wit about
why she's great I wonder you wanna do
how the [ __ ] that was actually pretty
tough six this [ __ ] say he eat
popped our cherry cherry pop tart and
explain to me what the missing told dogs
hey cuz I wrote the lyrics right and my
sixth grade teacher shoutout miss : she
was the [ __ ] dopest I wrote him and
she read it and she's like no you got to
change these because they have to be
school appropriate so I forgot what I
think I was oh I think I put ho some
like that she got to change it so like
the only thing is she was like Alex
you're very talented but oh no I think
it was I was like I got a lot of uh get
a get a lot of money like I lost the toe
or so like I lost the big toe some [ __ ]
I think was like I get a lot of money
and I get a lot of hoes I think that's
what I originally put and she was a
[ __ ] twelve-year-old ilogger my
teacher ID like it well you know this
part where you say you're slicing a lot
of throats because you are the goat this
one here I'm snorting a lot of coke and
I just stole your boat [ __ ] ass hoe
let's delicious and here it says you
stole my purse and use my money is that
true I came back my review of this was a
personal thing and you just broke our
trust yeah yeah so like it letting you
know I was right facts I know and then I
think it was probably around like
freshman years where we started getting
into more meta music like hardcore and
my brother got a guitar for Christmas
and was playing and our friend Tony was
playing and then they were like oh we
want to start a band be our vocalist I
was just like all right so like almost
like a lot of my songs were rap songs so
a lot of like the band songs the moment
we got pretty good before we like
officially stopped doing it a lot of
them were rap songs and I would just
scream them so like I want you to do
that rap one more time yeah all right
there we go hey bust a beat for me real
quick boom chick boom live guy hey my
black shoes on with an all-white shirt
yeah people look at me like I look like
dirt forget them hoes ain't no fool I
ride on 20 photos on my way to school
but no I ain't black but I ain't white
ass no facts got a lot of stuff like I
lost the toe I got a lot of friends I
got a lot of money and I don't like
sugar about our light honey honey hey
I'm in sixth grade I'm not that smart my
favorite gun is flown with is the cherry
pop sorry no four foot a so I ain't that
saw so in that bathroom I pee in the
star no I know how to do the ABCs oh
you're not just one tell her so I don't
eat cheese about to go right about now I
don't want to answer my angel with a bow
agent that [ __ ] was [ __ ] fired oh
yeah I somewhat someone that's watching
this needs to cut that up and put a beat
to it has to do that I have never been
so motivated in my life to eat pop-tarts
cut off my toe black shoes and look like
dirt hey you know what this is this just
follow your dreams kids I was watching
that what was cool about that right it
was cuz it was me and my friend at the
time Ray he had a song called white
shoes I don't know the lyrics and you
said [ __ ] you not actually but yeah we
need black shoes and white shoes and I
remember I wrote the song because my I
just picture ray upset at us [ __ ] he's
like I'm
I remember why I wrote it - cuz my my
auntie got me some like Reebok with like
the straps over and sure they were all
black I was like yo these are fresh on
my wearing a mess today
leigh-anne kind of led into that and I
was doing rap music and [ __ ] like that
but that was something that I could
never do I remember I wanted to do rap
so bad back in the day as a bunch of
Asian geeks and nerds Dubin you're too
scared to battle rap and this is like
what MC Jin came on shoutout yeah
remember 106 & Park yeah man check it
[ __ ] something they probably made in
China I forgot that I'm sorry name is
sterling because all you rock is silver
oh yeah the first battle rap that he did
shout-out to MC Jin he was battling this
dude Hassan and I remember a Fatman
Scoop was like worried about Hassan and
he goes no Hassan get focused and I
think when he said that it kind of
ruined his confidence a little bit he
just [ __ ] rocked him and it was funny
because back in the day when they were
doing battle reps and still to this day
like you know the only thing you really
got against an Asian guy is racist Asian
joke so I remember his first day you
don't want to mess with this cat Hassan
I'll get you back in the cut you cook
cooking fried wontons yo whose hole and
I was like oh and that's a time this
[ __ ] was a hot [ __ ] line but then Jin
was so [ __ ] good at that 106 & Park
battle he was just murdering I feel like
I never lost I remember he like he was
he would always win no he won every
single round that's how he that's how he
got that [ __ ] label deal with Ruff
Ryders
mmhmm yeah right dude and then he know
yeah then he dropped that [ __ ] song
y'all gonna learn Chinese which was a
trash song it was sad because like he
wanted to rock with Ruff Ryders because
I was like his [ __ ] and they didn't
market him correctly he had him do a
song called y'all gonna learn Chinese
it's like come on
Ruff Ryders was like DMX and [ __ ] right
huh okay that's why I told jugs about
this I some no hey no no I loved your
shout-out to DMX as well you [ __ ]
insane I wish like so I like I like I
wish I could sing so it's funny like you
wait you never got into rap right did
you want to get interrupts
oh I would I would write [ __ ] and it's
just sucked yes I've always wanted to be
able to sing but like I can't really
sing so because I used to uh when I used
to try to rap like I I think I have a
very good general knowledge of music I
know when [ __ ] sucks and I'm like this
is gonna be far right and I hit that B I
start rapping I'm high school as well
it's it's hard like um yeah I was doing
it I was writing raps from when I was
like in third grade when I wrote about
Sonic so I would just write a bunch of
[ __ ] how do you wrote now how could you
remember the [ __ ] sixth grade one dog
that's like four years
don't you remember that it went away um
no yeah so I've always wanted to sing
but then once auto-tune came around like
you know how to use it like that [ __ ]
that's my baby right there so I like I
like making rap music we were really
liked rap like hardcore rap music you
know like waka flocka and [ __ ] yeah
I wasn't I can't the freestyling I'm
gonna lose so if you want to freestyle
battle me just take the W I don't know
you a real rep you know what [ __ ] all
the new artists can't battle rap anyways
yeah that's like a complete separate
honor I feel like the guys that are
really good they're free styles yeah
really make good music it's weird right
so I feel like this podcast is brought
to you by molecule my friends do you
have an old air purifier in your home
maybe you're thinking to have it sell I
have a HEPA air filter
I'm good HEPA air filters are old as
heck I'm talking 70 years old molecule
my friends don't play that game and it's
beyond just helping you out with your
allergies let me tell you what molecule
purifies in that dang air molecule is
your best defense against allergy season
because molecule has a reinvented the
air purify to destroy airborne
pollutants including allergens bacteria
mold viruses and volatile organic
compounds also known as VOCs yes using
breakthrough photo electrochemical
oxidation molecule air purifiers don't
just collect air pollutant
they destroy them on the molecular level
if you are sneezing your butt off I bet
you at the beginning of this year you
had a nice fat ass but you sneezed it
right off and you know why because you
don't have a molecule I've been sneezing
so much lately because of this spring
season my butt is nearly gone and I have
nothing to sit on what molecule is gonna
come to save the day no more sneezing my
ass off how about that molecule destroys
pollutants that other filters collect
traditional filters collect larger
pollutants but smaller ones like viruses
and volatile organic chemicals VOCs can
slip right through molecule uses
breakthrough signs to break down these
pollutants on a molecular level and
that's what I'm talking about yes is air
purification for your whole home
molecule destroys airborne pollutants on
a molecular level and because it's
science developed over 20 years by the
director of the Clean Energy Research
Center at the University of South
Florida son I don't know how many things
I have to say to talk about its validity
but just to say this molecule is a valid
Sun so check it out for 10 percent off
your first air purifier order visit
molecule calm as an M oh l EK UL e calm
and a check out enter brain once again
for 10% off your first air purifier
order visit M o le kul e calm and at
checkout enter brain get to breathe and
baby molecule the definition of what it
meant to be in like an MC and a hip-hop
artist that definition has changed a lot
right so if you were a rapper back in
the day like usually you had a great
amount of street cred with you like it
wasn't something that you could do
without having that right cuz almost it
was like that was like your stripes if
you don't have your stripes you nobody
gave a [ __ ] about your raps because
specifically back in the day from what I
remember as a kid a lot of that [ __ ] was
gangster [ __ ] because before stuff
became real radio right and they started
to being like love songs and also the
[ __ ] then there was like the R&B singer
mixed with the [ __ ] the rapper and
then you have my [ __ ] LL Cool J
talking about licking your lips and
suddenly perhaps [ __ ] and knocking
people out cuz his momma told him to
there you go right and there was like
all this other another other type of
hip-hop and he started slowly
transforming into something else
nowadays you have like a lot of these
new rappers they don't have to
rap and I'm not knocking them on that
that's just how it evolved yeah so like
most rappers when you come up to me like
you'll listen if they were to get in a
circle and they asked him to freestyle
they most likely can't do it because
just a skill all right and then yeah and
you can tell like it'd be like the same
[ __ ] like I'd be gone to the stall then
I went to the other stove then I went to
the Joey stove who went to the coffee
stove like it'd be like the same [ __ ]
like yeah and people can't do it and
I've ever been another thing I want you
to freestyle right now no papi
you gotta do right now after you like I
feel like [ __ ] okay we gonna do it about
you going to the stove do it next right
after you now going to the stove oh I
see you two moving up that doubt okay oh
I might go buy a little dough okay
make some bread I don't even know she
owes already babe before okay go ahead
stop me not [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah I see
a little bit I'm like what's happening
was Brett hey uh I'm done I don't know
how was it it was Bartle like the
coronavirus like what's up with yo hey
yo a give it give n a lot a guys on the
top here's a restyle about here's the no
no no no we're not we're not explaining
it now you Tommy okay go ahead you don't
want to hear me rap oh yes we do Michael
oh yes we are a hundred percent right
now yeah I don't work in front you guys
[ __ ] let's see it what am I gonna make
You rabbi right now Harlem spit that um
let's see talk about tops restaurant
tops restaurant don't you love that she
doesn't go [ __ ] what runs with favorite
why you chose the alright the first word
up go youth it's okay you can do the
harms why the beats building up so
usually have a ghostwriter so like we go
go we go
it takes me some lines real quick at
Texas and wines my name's Nick Dunne and
I'm here to say I like having my friends
and I'm elated David what'd you figure
out
give me anything Bravo rapping hey you
can fit a rap about forgetting memory
cards okay there's no warrior body he
knows I listen
so yesterday I was up in the podcast
room picking up from the rap and [ __ ]
do [ __ ] like so a guy's you could have
said you finna record [ __ ] on my zoom on
my thumb thank you thank you rather that
got [ __ ] rap gosh you got a sneaker are
you hungry
hey what's the baby the biggest fat boy
[ __ ] ever
I like all this boy fat because he's
like 80% muscle but this dude he was
like we were sitting here haha try to
split this you know I've never heard a
person who cares about their help say
y'all try to the [ __ ] has a full sized
snicker bar in their pocket Snickers and
it's also melted shut this [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] warm right now you know sleepers
had the design on top it's just smooth
this is my guy bro you know why cuz
yesterday up he were playing it were
plans to call duty and he was like yo
man he was asking people hey you guys
want some diets diet 7up yeah we see
bruh cakes hey shout out to my homie
Hulk if you watch this I don't know you
do but like you were hella cool right so
I was just making sure he good so I we
plan on my yo ho he like was good homie
on my have you been washing your hands
for 20 and he's like yeah I'm surprised
I got zebra cakes too in the back so the
and then after he said that it got me
thinking I was I yell with the [ __ ]
zebra cake so he looked at our [ __ ]
hood sack and I never I never had zebra
cakes because my parents would never let
me eat them miss Debbie once but I would
have they're like the little Nutter
Butter ones like the chocolate way not
the zebra cakes one but the sit-up and
the cinnamon buns cinnamon bun
the honey bun honey honey bun malicious
lappers dude but I asked I asked Alex
last night I was a bro brick I was just
kind of messing around I was a hey give
me some zebra cakes and he was like hey
don't trip this fool pulls up to my
I like nine o'clock at night I'll ever
take Wonder Bread and just dip that in
sugar water that's with sugar water
that's what zebra zebra cakes lat hey
you met you guys know those little like
twirls are like the pecan a little
cinnamon those little twirl those look
like little Cinnabons they actually look
like little like a cinnamon would look
but they're pecan yeah slap have you
guys ever had a super doughnut the
[ __ ] zoo that I remember just in like
guys making up snow would would school
elementary yet for breakfast he used to
give us a little super donuts slap I
know I know people will know what the
super done' is tell these fools how
banda [ __ ] is slap so you should try
still too every time i one second well
you know you know what's better is the
LAUSD you guys didn't grow up out here
so but they have the LAUSD cocktails
have years have them where you guys grew
up a Starbuck coffee cake slap now the
LAUSD coffee can and they don't want to
tell you right now if you had to steal
[ __ ] honey buns bro you were poor as
[ __ ] cuz honey buns were like they were
given it was like 99 cents for seven of
them yeah no super donuts were farm dude
yeah the honey buns are good what's the
black one with a little white twirl
host:so Ding Dongs whatever the way hoes
like the the longer ones right like this
the hostess cakes are hostess cakes
that's it yeah those ones and speaking
of this to number one I don't know why
Twinkies are so much more expensive than
all the other ones they're all the same
company right yeah but me and my homies
uh we had this little barbecue I don't
know if you ever tried this right you
get that Twinkie and you put it on the
barbecue like you put you flip it like
for a couple seconds
cook it yeah a little bit but a little
bit in the night [ __ ] come out like nice
and crispy that's just laughs you bite
it that little that little sucker I
don't know the last time I had a [ __ ]
about Twinkie I like ho ho's bad in a
State Fair when they deep-fry it how is
that not good I mean like State Fair
food is interesting right because all
this batter it's all bad or just all
decadent I mean you have a couple of
bites unless you're in the mood to eat a
lot of [ __ ] and then you're not gonna
like it yeah last time I went to the
fair I tried to like the little food
that they get to the goats
she was live yo what for you your [ __ ]
dog eating brother - let's talk about
eating real food
he's like oh you guys ever had the food
they have hamburgers with donut buns we
had three rabbit pellets to or what I
think it kind of looked like that a
little you know those little green thing
it look like the end of like a shoelace
you know uh so today we're gonna start a
GoFundMe just to get his [ __ ] head
right for some [ __ ] therapy dude why
did goat pellets even goats don't wanna
eat that [ __ ] but they have to pay now
the monkey that [ __ ] was a disgusting oh
my god all the moisture IKEA all the way
all the moisture in my mouth literally
disappeared once that [ __ ] exploded
why did you why did you eat it bro
what's the matter with you and why oh my
god cuz they had a that's the spot they
had a couple of this go just eating it
laughs would you just go much all that
if I was like there right and ago will I
and I staring at him I ate I good right
so I tried it I was like look it over a
shoulder like you should go get some I
was like you know I start a new show
just called put it in front of Alex I
see is it food or not that's what the
show's gonna be called is it food or
none cuz you don't give me my actual
[ __ ] like poopoo caca like I say but
that's the show it's just a white room
on the table right [ __ ] up is it food or
not and then alice is gonna decide that
what's on the table though huh white
table alright but it's just like the
plastic one with the circle doesn't
matter you're eating [ __ ] that's the
joke like you don't know that it's [ __ ]
but they do you all know that it's
always you have to say if its food or
not and then you eat it and you go
that's food and I'm like that's funny
because that literally came out of my
ass and I damn David what you'll die cuz
it be good she's like that locks a shell
was fired corn kernels cuz I'm so heated
right now right so everybody knows about
my little pad right that I stay at the
[ __ ] yeah five star you know Hilton
what it is dog I went down there to make
some popcorn in our microwave guess how
long I had to cook that [ __ ] for six
minutes
wait how old this is microwave doc
ancient popcorn
no that was our that was our popcorn
without a pop machine that was our
microwave - growing up I guarantee you
this man it is not a [ __ ] microwave
what it is is a glass door and then a
candle lit next to it and then a plate
spinning I would not be surprised I got
some more updates on the house dude it's
a flood edy bucket no so I went out
there and make the popcorn while looking
at the buttons and you know sometimes
you look over [ __ ] so fast so you like
read it read like four times you're like
I must be missing this [ __ ] right no
popcorn button oh my all right so
normally it's about like two two and a
half minutes on a normal thing right so
I do that in the bag is literally flat
after two and a half minutes I'm like
what the [ __ ]
so I'd do it for like another three and
a half minutes on my are let me just see
after six minutes there the bottom was
still filled with all the [ __ ] like
little seeds and [ __ ] I just looked at
that lady I might pop how often do you
like use that microwave not that often
you know cuz I'm chef I'd be cooking man
this guy actually started cooking meat
sauce look good dude and I'm Esau
Salinas crash - do you put um brown
sugar in your meat sauce nah man now you
don't need to push it I know you know I
guess it really depends so like when you
make tomato sauce just to just to help
y'all people out cooking with David so
cooking with David so so if I make
tomato sauce and it's not really from
scratch because obviously it comes from
a tin I'm not making them like from
fresh roma tomatoes I like to get San
marzanos so San marzanos are really
really [ __ ] sweet mmm like the actual
tomato it's like you're specific if you
look at the cannon just as san marzano
can also it's like tomatoes from like
yeah they get them at the peak of
ripeness and they can them right [ __ ]
sweet of [ __ ] so you don't really need
to add a lot of sugar to it so when you
make these tomato sauces a lot of people
uses sofrito right so that's celery
carrot and onions and the carrot is
there to add sweetness back to the
tomatoes San Marzano tomatoes are really
really sweet if you don't get San
marzanos you probably should add a
little sugar to it because it's a little
bland yeah it's not that sweet so yeah
that was the thing my great-grandma like
when we used to go visit her like our
favorite meal she used to make us was
spaghetti and like her thing that she
always says she's like all I do
different is I just drink a little brown
triggering it it's like ice kind of
always what I did but I did I did tomato
sauce I don't remember what your brand I
brought bought but I just got
straight-up tomato sauce right
I got 93 7% beef so it's a little better
you know I'm saying uh I got onions a
lot of fat but yeah anyway let's lean
only uh 97 for self at you would find
the pepper 97 percent fat can I get
taste of them so I got I did bell
peppers green red onion a little bit of
garlic and I cut like a lot of that up
and then jalapenos I got I cut up like
one jalapeno put it all in there I cook
those first in that little oil or
avocado oil put a little bit salt and
pepper on that with Lyday and then I
cook the meat separately just a little
bit like a slow cook right cuz when you
slow cook the flavor really sits inside
of the meat David so listen cuz I know
you don't know how to cook beef right so
and then you sprinkle some stuff all
over it I have sprinkle some stuff all
over and then so like salt pepper I put
a little bit of garlic salt cuz I don't
like it my meat like too salty you know
like people put a lot of garlic salt and
[ __ ] I can just immediately taste all
the saw so I did that cook that
separately cook those separately and
then I put the sauce the tomato sauce in
the like what are they called vegetables
in the [ __ ] then I put the meat in there
money what do they call remember I [ __ ]
they come from the earth talk about you
that grow from Earth talk about your
steak recipe remember that you remember
how you cook your steaks like do it I
don't know all I know is it took for
[ __ ] ever
it should never take forever I know I
like I said what I did is right when I
turn on the heat I put the steak on okay
I don't think we did so so Alex we're at
shabu shabu
alex comes up to us shabu shabu fire
shot was shot with fire he goes yo man
like I cooked some steak last night that
[ __ ] was bomb and then he looked at us
and he goes hey are you supposed to flip
the steak and I was like my god yes we
did question we didn't know it's not we
didn't understand what you were he was
asking and he goes and I asked him like
what did you use to season it with he
goes oh just pepper
I don't like salt I just only put pepper
on my steak
sure I don't like stop for some reason I
can like taste salt like so harsh
sometimes that's the widest thing I've
ever heard you say know what I think no
salt wanna know why me and my mom and my
brothers talking about this cuz we were
kids we used to take those ramen blocks
mm-hmm just break it up and then take
that salt the seasoning just pour it in
and eat it like [ __ ] that's just [ __ ]
salty as hell what's just msg no dog
assault it's a sauce dude that [ __ ] like
I tried that just recently maybe like a
year gonna hurt one bite I was like yo a
headache all the shadows I [ __ ] yes
man a lot of the kids I grew up with
used to do that and I used to always
look at him like why would you guys do
that I would never understand why they
would it was like so cool it was like a
cool thing it was like a snack me that I
mean I would do that but then I wouldn't
use the whole pack I would use about
half of it
no I dumped that whole I put that my
parents would get mad at me if I am her
I try that one time when my mom got
really mad at me stuff even hurt my
stomach like that raw or without it
cooked or gotta cook I started hurting
my stomach stop eating it yeah sometimes
we'll just buy chips you know 100
percent yeah you could I mean if we had
chip money do you got money you got made
Donal money a lot of fast food growing
up only on special occasions
I don't know once I got out of high
school I would eat fast oh man
the the most weight I've ever gained in
the the fastest amount was right when I
went to college yeah and I could eat a
lot of fast food a lot of cuz you know
they had that 29:29 saying yeah you had
the 29 said in the 39 said cheeseburger
I'm at McDonald's McDonald's I don't
know this is like the [ __ ] poor people
holy grail of food I remember I said
right when I came back I was like I saw
a sophomore and I liked American
violence I came home and I was like oh
hi yo do you guys know that there's
cheeseburgers were like a dollar like
yeah like 75 cents they look at me like
my parents look at me like oh don't eat
that all the time though you idiot
Burger King - look w guys remember that
yeah that was but yeah now I can tell
because that I used to bring so much
annoying people there people used to go
there can I get 30 bucks doubles on my
[ __ ] man come on you know long that [ __ ]
take the cookies yeah but no I didn't
know I never knew McDonald's how that
[ __ ] twenty-nine cents a ham
and 39 cents cheeseburgers I forgot
those days but they got filet-o-fish
Fridays now I want to go get a
filet-o-fish no I got to get a big fish
this is [ __ ] wack man Ernest all
Jaques Fame the big fish head [ __ ] you
taught my bird King some fish sandwich
right yeah have you ever eaten trash
before actually yeah have you ever even
[ __ ] Gopal's before actually no a no
what will you see it a lot when we were
growing up when we would get fast food
we do like it be Arby's a lot because
they have like those it was like the
onion bun with the roast beef and the
cheese I only had Arby's recently for
the first time it was at this past
couple months ago dude I was hard but
last time I went to Arby's Darby sauce
I'm like duh right and they forgot to
put in the bag i sat there at Arby's is
[ __ ] bottles no as long as you pour
extra sauce all over that sandwich do we
have an Arby's hammer remember this one
right there cuz I live close to that one
or like Barstow or something I think
there's one in Pasadena - I don't know
there's only one it uh yeah but that
bird King fish sandwich is trash man now
you got to make it my way that's why
what is your way not the King way you
know they say have it your way that's
what I did okay tell me how do we have
it our way so normally you know they put
that tartar sauce that [ __ ] trash throw
that in the garbage throw that garbage
out trash in the sea bro now you go put
it in the dumpster they put it in the
sea so you people do not put your
[ __ ] trash in the ocean please or the
Harter sauce yeah nah cuz they like
don't they like fire it up and dissolve
initiative oh no they do a trash
whatever they do it try and let them
that is the funniest [ __ ] thing I've
ever heard of my life that's a [ __ ]
right there so they fired a [ __ ] up and
dissolve me to go into the earth in the
sky bring it in and there's some time
when a nasty cried that's why it's all
good you know when you bird garbage
right he turns into stars in the sky and
then uh so what you do is instead of
putting that tartar sauce on there right
you cook that that fish in the oil if
the oil is fresh that [ __ ] slap anything
from Burger King with like that has to
be fried is good and then so you put it
on that button they use a different bun
they don't use like the normal what to
see yeah yeah
so you put it on there you put a ketchup
and then you put the fish ketchup dog
the way you set up pisses me off
ketchup and then you put the fish on
there you put tomatoes cheese and they
meant already ketchup on that fish
sandwich I hate it
no I'm dudes anyway does it come with
tomato and lettuce of all that not
really I think so if I were to go ask
that for the Burger King people they
wouldn't get mad at me for asking for
all that [ __ ] on the on that sandwich
you don't think they get mad because it
seems like you put some ketchup and then
you you squish it like this right what
you do David you hold it like this it
depends on how you take that first bite
- I hate when you give people food and I
like like right off the tip and they
only eat the bun of [ __ ] you know I'm
talking about how I gotta eat the burger
you gotta hold that [ __ ] and take a big
bite through the middle though like the
fact that you have that all that [ __ ] to
that sandwich that's too much worth I
know I know what I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna buy you guys one so you guys know
I'm not gonna weigh my money on the [ __ ]
watch okay watch this though this is
what I do when I go to McDonald's
filet-o-fish sandwich right I buy it
right how do you human being without any
goat pellets yeah do you oh my go
hey man you got a goat i order my food I
just put a sack on the table though like
what's that miles go pellets don't know
that's my Elfie but I did not have you
guys ever had the fish murmuring no yeah
[Laughter]
Burger King and also the fish sandwich
from Carl's jr. sucks dick cause you
know for some reason I'm so weirded out
about cause I don't know like I don't
trust their fish sandwiches I the only
fish that rise from their friends
McDonald Chris the Caesar - Chris Pratt
Chris Craig hey hold on a flat so [ __ ]
they got a fight I go like the quickest
way to a bet it's so good
now they do um there's a little bit
musics for the rest of pocket Arby's has
curly fries those are bomb better than
the deck in about what eh and look at
Arby's hungred you know I'll get you
some Harvey let's go Jay put some sauce
on it now yeah I'm telling you that BK
fish with the way I said it guys go to
BK that you can get your [ __ ] I mean the
slogans have it your way right know it
people are weird I used to work there
people used to be like can I get the
whopper and I have it all separate
though why I would I wish I could ask
them that but you can't ask them right
you just like the show but we a ya know
so we'd have to get a box for everything
a box for the bun a box for the meat
under capture packets manage packets
mustard packets a box for the lettuce
separate from the tomatoes separate from
the onion and give them everything I'm
like what's the point I would say no I
might no we can't do that yeah it was
like it's out I'm like imagine how
expensive that is for Burger King yeah
but it's like you're gonna just put it
back together we could have just done
this [ __ ] for you what's the difference
maybe they are driving 40 miles and
they're gonna eat the [ __ ] that's the
only bird King in the area yeah and they
don't want the like bun and get soggy or
some [ __ ] maybe but I used to hate that
[ __ ] I can I get it all separate you
like how how often would you get that Do
It Yourself you'd be surprised man
there's so much like so much weird [ __ ]
that goes on my Burger King man [ __ ] it
though
well guys podcast and we're gonna end
this with the song in elementary school
hit it Alex
let me get that beat hey turn off that
snare a little bit louder hey hey hey
put my black shoes on we're not white
shirt white shirt look at me and like I
look like dirt trash damn food no food a
ride on 24 on my way to schools yeah no
I ain't black but I'm why - no no blend
a lot of stuff like I love my toe why I
got a lot of friends yeah got a lot of
money no I don't like sugar but give me
that honey I mean say it's great I'm not
that smart
huh favorite kind of food is a cherry
pot sorry I'm for for a joint that's all
yeah I'm in the bathroom
a penis stuff I don't know how to say
the ABCs now I'm lactose intolerant so I
don't need cheese I'm about to go right
about now huh don't wanna answer let's
end it wit about you guys can catch the
genius pretty podcasts on all audio
platforms you guys can catch their
podcast a big mad podcast how do you
spell that
stupid shitty i GGG mad you're bi GGG
mad Reggie for each one of us gee
pitbull jeez that's axel uh that's
actual a man I'm having a stroke this
whole di might be you this far is hook
this thing about Arby's right now dude
that's right Patrick T Riley is also on
the podcast we're actually switching a
new podcast to a new place right now
we're in transition I'm getting a
contractor to work on it right now so
all your guys's patreon money is not
being used for my purse yes so it looks
nice too so you guys will be happy we
can't waste an integer it's gonna be
dope super comfortable catches every
Thursdays and Sundays these guys will
probably be hitting these guys up to do
the podcast with me because I got nobody
else
during this Corona situation so uh catch
y'all next time pop-tarts